map of Asia labeling it do I know it
find out I'm not great with geography I
would say I know it a decent amount when
my friends are parking their car and I'm
with them like I know how to get us back
to the car I'd have to count for
something I would say I did really well
in high school and I made a hundred on
like the world test but I didn't realize
would be all downhill after that seventh
grade Becky knew geography very well cuz
I had a placemat growing up my parents
would watch CNN and make me pick
countries thirty-year-old Becky not so
much can we talk about this like what
kind of jagged puzzle piece bootleg like
what did where did y'all get this map I
would have appreciated colors can I just
say that I know I know what this is
about we are all having a laugh like
haha you don't know but with that said I
don't mean to be offensive countries I
switch I don't mean to imply I don't
think you mattered you know what I mean
I just wanted to like I love this caveat
honestly is it too much to apologize now
or should I just like wait till the end
of the video apologize I'm so sorry
so we've been given a list with the
names we have about 15 minutes we're
grading this on a curve that's what I
heard
oh yeah however the other groups do yeah
let's just try to be better than the
other groups done okay ready Dave is
there a part that you feel more
confident about geography boys start
with your first most confident what up
my name's Zach I'm a geography boy and
today I'm telling you guys where China
is okay well that's India I mean I think
we should leave on top thank you very
much that's it that's the end of it feel
like we're 100% right Japan okay yes
North Korea and South Korea Sri Lanka I
think the easiest other one is like
Russia totally the ocean good extra
credit and then I know that this here is
Indonesia this is Russia Russia is not
on here and that's worrying me wait is
Russia considered Asian half no okay
well alright Russia is considered part
of Asia it's divided it is directors
shaking his head it's not half of Russia
is considered in Asia
y'all need to check stuff before you put
us out here
that's India yes yeah yeah yeah ok
that's India Malaysia that I think this
I think this is Malaysia Japan I know
it's an island well I feel good about
that one this is Saudi Arabia
Mongolia is here in between the Huns
okay yeah that is not good I think this
is North Korea and South Korea which
makes sense because north
you're not read this north and south
that's the trick though if we if they
can't read our handwriting they don't
know if it's right or not yeah there's
so many little little names I didn't
know about I think this is Kazakh yeah I
think it is I think that's Mongolia
because like Tibet and everything Shh
duh yeah uh-huh Philippines nor Turkey
this is Turkey I love it I feel like
this is all like Middle East is that
part of Asia
okay so this is Turkey I think turkey
actually wait let me help you with this
I just realized this is oh man and then
it goes into Yemen oh you know where
they are
yeah there's a sliver that would be
Israel and then above it yeah I love
that yeah oh wait I know where the
Philippines are you do yeah this is the
Philippines cool so we also establish
that we've never been to Asia oh that's
a great thing to tell them cuz we have
it never been this okay so this is Syria
and then this is Jordan I think balls
this is Syria and this is Jordan I'm
gonna make you make a gut call Iraq boom
boom bear okay hmm
where are the Maldives this I know this
little guy that's guitar okay and then
that is a country or that just a lake
which one is Iran do you feel like it's
that one well dad we have to make calls
I'm just gonna do it let's do it okay
love it love that Iran's there this is
Iraq um okay we just gonna start putting
stuff right so like yeah Thailand whoa
Malaysia I'm a baker okay we're come all
day just want to go there okay this is
Thailand oh I think I'm wrong okay we're
making the executive call okay I say we
gotta do it so this is Cambodia I say
this is Singapore this
is my mom yeah all right and then that's
Vietnam okay good I know Cyprus wait
Chris where no no you're on to something
you've got it it's a it's an island
I know Cyprus is an island close to the
Maltese
I wrote it baby
which one it's here it's here all right
I'm saying this is mine this is you
Guinean Wow and that is a bad way Wow
have we thought about Bangladesh as an
option you know I haven't how do you
feel about this being Bangladesh I like
it I'm gonna lock it in
yeah Bangladesh that's what about it I
know the stands are in here somewhere
just gonna put the stand
what Indonesia and I'm also starting to
think get this its Vietnam I don't know
where Fiji is Marshall Islands yeah guys
Bee Gees an island just start labeling
your islands back Saudi Arabia feels
like a mistake okay I'm gonna say this
is Fiji he was naming bold
I like the boldness you said Cypress is
this line have we done kuwait kuwait now
all right I don't think we can consider
it giving up yeah
for the sake of time yeah if you guys
need to quit we can quit we did a
bang-up job you know a whopping five hi
say I want to hear what everybody else
did before I started by myself and then
we got a happy wife even if it was very
close plus 18 out of it was nice
teachers nice Oh nineteen and a half you
don't really do half points you round up
and that
okay not bad people got 13 out of 55 oh
they gave they gave him something extra
credit for like coming close yeah no no
I'm not denying on okay fine
honestly yeah we didn't get any credit
for stands yeah how do you feel about
the Maldives being over here I like the
location here vacation but I hate that I
put it dude I'm just gonna say I'm sorry
[Music]